une excellente qualité mais une quantité
médiocre le bilan des moissons de blé et
d'orge dans les yvelines en 2020 les
agriculteurs continuent de moissonner
jusqu'à la fin juillet des récoltes
stocker notamment ici dans cette
coopérative a d'avron au coeur de la
plaine de versailles
vous voyez le blé comme glace et le
millésime 2000 ventes très bonne qualité
nous avons des td des poids spécifique
des albères des indices dax baird sont
des indices de panification ainsi que
des taux de protéines qui sont tout à
fait honorables voire très bon dans le
département des yvelines
une centaine d'agriculteurs du centre et
du nord des yvelines sont adhérents à
cette coopérative elle accueille les
céréales et les stocks pour assurer la
conservation et la commercialisation
principal constat négatif pour cette
saison une baisse de la quantité d'au
moins 20% par rapport à 2010 9 comme au
niveau national on a eu plus beaucoup
plus haut mais tri à partir de fin
octobre
donc on était amené à semer des cultures
dans des conditions des fois moyenne
ensuite la grande sécheresse du mot du
printemps vous savez bien le mois
d'avril où il est tombé quasiment 0 mm
donc plus d'un mois sans une goutte
d'eau on avait avant des traitements de
semences qui nous assurer une protection
contre les insectes et que maintenant on
a plus qui a un petit peu rebattu les
cartes
le facteur climatique a impacté la
culture céréalière conséquences aussi
sur la taille de la paille plus courte
cette année pour tous qui élevage
évidemment les gens qui d'habitude
ramasse 50 hectares de paille ils auront
besoin de plus de surface pour
simplement avoir les mêmes quantités
dans les récoltes stockés dans cette
coopérative 50% sont prévus pour
l'export
les 50 autres sont vendus dans des
meunerie française dans les yvelines la
majorité des surfaces agricoles sont
consacrées aux cultures de blé d'orge et
de colza